this is interesting because it doesn't
look exactly like any of the things that
we've done it's kind of not just Franken
fashion this other stuff kind of flavor
graph so you have some choices okay in
mathematics is always lots of different
parts Twitter's he's option one may
benefit option one is well if this
problem doesn't look like one of the
ones that I already know how to deal
with well I can just make it look like
one of the ones that I do so I'm not
gonna this is actually not gonna be the
thing you end up doing but if I wanted
to why this looks different is because
the right-hand side is not one fraction
do you agree like if it were then we
could go to one of these we'll be fine
so therefore just take this guy and turn
him into one fraction it's not that
complicated right I would have a common
denominator for both of these and then
you can put fractions together so if I
wanted if this is over three what would
X be if it was over three I think it
would be three x over three right
do you agree that that and X are
identical now it doesn't seem like why
would you do that why would you make
that more complicated exits file or the
reason why is sin that now can talk to
this but you see that narrower because
they have a common denominator I can
make one fraction out of it that's 3x
take away one on see that so if I got to
that point now I have fraction on the
left fraction on the right and then
either these be fine like I said cross
multiply okay however I want to pull you
back to the original question and think
about is there no way one that doesn't
require us to do this okay
remember the whole issue we're trying to
do with these fractions where they're
just kind of pesky right so here I'm
gonna think about this doesn't look as
obvious but actually this technique
what's brilliant about it is that it's
very topical versatile like you can use
it
a bunch of different examples right so
have a look I have fractions in fact if
you were carefully I have exactly the
same denominators that I have there as I
have here right you see that five and a
three so what one number would I
multiply by everything to get rid of
those and the answer is 15 just like
before right so this is what I'm gonna
do
15 out front I'll put the brackets there
to indicate I'll multiply it off my
whole thing over five and then
everything over here I'm also going to
multiply by 15 okay so now this goes
back to expand the brackets and so on
hey this is nice and simple I can cancel
right what am I gonna get and I cancel
this five I gave three right and that's
three three X plus two
let's expect these Rapids 15 times X is
just 15 times 1/3 is it's a third of 15
which is five don't forget that the sign
comes along for the right then I just
expand this guy and I don't even really
need to finish this item of the thing I
reckon you could probably get the rest
of it on your own like getting to this
point is the hard part now we just want
to collect like terms and we'll get
about my friends okay so leave that on
the board you can have a crap yet and
you remember finish off I will